the kardashians in shock over Rob's new  girlfriend  so ET has confirmed Rob Kardashian and  blac Chyna are officially dating blac  Chyna as in the ex of Kylie Jenner's  current boyfriend Tyga yeah it's  obviously pretty awkward and a source  tells ET kylie is quote livid about the  situation our source says they started  dating about two weeks ago and the  Kardashian family is quote in shock over  the relationship honestly were in shock  to all this time Rob's been reclusive  didn't really think dating was on his  mind but let's remember they've known  each other for a while blac Chyna has a  long history with the Kardashians she'd  even been on the show before as Kim's  friend at a pole-dancing class well you  know what they say  all your sisters and their boyfriends  exes